just like before when we started this
topic which conic section did we begin
with we start with the parabola and the
reason why is because it was a nice easy
case to think about even though now that
you know all this stuff you might think
Ultima logically start with the circle
because that's like your basic case but
you can see it sort of breaks down
mathematically because it doesn't have
the ratio the eccentricity that we're
talking about okay that's always time Oh
problem I'm gonna do the same thing for
figure out the different kinds of
equations that it has so Cartesian
equations x squared equals 4a y I'm
sticking of the a in there
because it's important for when we have
the parametric equations you're going to
get a pair of equations in terms of a
parameter remember this you'll have an x
equals and away what were they to 80 and
80 squared good and the critical thing
about this was that if you put them
together if you sub one into the other
you get the Cartesian equation back so
these two occur into this one now we
also know parametric equations for
another of the conic sections you know
it already it's just that we didn't
usually call it a parametric equation
which one wasn't it's a circle isn't it
now we didn't usually call it a
parametric equation we usually call it
something else had to do with angles and
get to in a second let's just think
about a basic one and then we'll
generalize in the next room okay
x-ray plus y squared equals one it also
has a pair of equations that define is x
value and it's Y values
what were the coordinates it's a trick
thing wasn't it and it's it's silent
cause but which ones which X's X's
clause and the way I remember it is it's
alphabetical
and that makes why sign and of course
you can draw the unit circle for
yourself and you'll see college refers
to said that horizontal distance hence X
and sign refers to the vertical distance
that's why now we actually gave it a
different name remember when we do
because it has to do with this angle we
often call them polar coordinates
because that's fine things in terms of
angle and radius okay so what are we
visit that wonder center now if that's
what a circle is we know an ellipse is
something that was the unit circle if
all I change is I make the circle bigger
how are the polar coordinates the
parameter equations how they can change
well they're going to get further out
further away from the origin by a factor
of the radius right so that's gonna be
our closed theta and this will be sine
theta and that's the only difference
okay now I can move on to the ellipse
now being that Italy this is just a
circle that's been stretched out in
different ways okay if we consider the
basic one which has its center at the
origin okay let's see about this
equation is this already got its
proportions built into it based on a m--
be okay intuition kind of tells you well
the cause inside things should still
sort of be happening right because it's
still going around and around in the
same way and these are the they're also
called secular functions if you remember
that but they're not gonna go around and
around in this neat way this equal way
right sometimes you'll be further across
than you are
hi rather than exactly the same amount
okay so how do we account for that well
how do we get R cos theta outside why do
we multiply by our Y we do that
I'll change the radius right we know
that freezes if I was 525 we're just
going to be the same things but further
away okay and how much further away was
the radius now it's going to be squared
ah
how much further away you are
horizontally or vertically right because
if I make this a really be number this a
small number that makes you really fat
or vice versa
okay so therefore instead of R cos theta
he's just gonna have a Constantino
that's how far across you can go right a
is what defines how wide your lips will
be and in the same way because Y is
operating on a completely different
system based on how tall a squad commits
you it would be so thinner right now we
have one last cone except two more done
today now we sort of did some logic and
then proofs geometrically are very very
simple for all of these ok the hyperbola
is not so neat okay so what I'm gonna do
is I will give you the parametric
equations and we're just going to show
that they work but I'm not going to
derive the actual results because they
will take you forever and you won't gain
that much out of it really it's just
your head sort of spins with Jigen it's
confusing okay so we're gonna go right
so I think your memories should be yeah
okay you're like where does that come
from and the answer is some wacko
geometry but let's just quickly make
ourselves contend that it's works and
it's a very very simple trig identity
that'll let us do it okay what were you
saying at the beginning the parametric
equations when you stick them together
you should get the Cartesian equation
right so because I've got a special
effects and Y all I have to do is
something big and let's see what happens
so I'll take the left-hand side I'm
gonna have let's say a squared sinh
squared + B squared 10 squared that's
what I've done so I know where I want to
end right so there should be some funky
canceling out here right the a squared
to the B Squared's cancel that's nice
now here you can see SEC squared and
hands wet clearly there's the
Pythagorean identity that's going to
come to play now I don't know about you
but I always found it a nightmare to try
and remember is that 1 minus 10 squared
is 6 foot or the other way around always
found the computer okay so here's the
way that I do it just go back to the
original sine squared must close squared
equals 1 right everyone remembers that
people don't seem to have trouble with
that which is great ok how do you go
from this one - the one with tangent it
what do we do to everything on that line
you divided by cos square right so
divide that one you get 10 squared
- by this one you get 1 and then you
have your reciprocal identity along the
end so that's a really nice foolproof
way of never screwing it up therefore
I'm gonna stick that in there so I get
my tan squared plus 1 minus tan squared
which is the one that I was expecting so
this works it does actually satisfy the
Cartesian equation alright so the proof
you can look it up but it's kind of long
involved and I don't think it's that
very short for you guys
but here's the point you can use all of
these to solve questions in a way that's
a bit easier sometimes it maybe needs
less that's logic if you like so let me
show you go back to one of those
questions where you had to prove that
the distance from Authority the distance
from any point on the ellipse pick a
point okay and sure the distance to the
two foci to remember this like here's
one for focus and there's the other one
so what we call them s and s - you had
to prove this right
what were they equal to also some equal
to we wanted to prove that they were
equal to the major axis and we did some
sort of chopping and changing to do that
right what do we use we used the locus
definition of the ellipse now if I have
exact values for the XS and the Y's it's
just algebra
what okay PS what is s what are its
coordinates it's the focus where is it
it's a key isn't it
zero okay and correspondingly this is -
a zero okay so therefore I can just say
well what is penis
what's it equal to it's a square root
of-- well this is just a distance
formula isn't it I'm gonna go from these
coordinates hey the sign so these chords
I'll just do this case and then the
other one follows very easily okay
what's gonna go underneath the square
root what we got a cos theta minus AE
squared plus B sine theta minus coz I'm
on the are on the on the axis is just
zero isn't it hey look at this you got
square root of a squared cos squared 2 a
squared e cos ya yes
a squared a squared B squared sine
squared you like for real
look at that thing that's a mess okay
it's actually not that bad think about
it you've got so many sine squared sin
cos squared you're gonna use this guy
okay you've got a Z's and B's squared so
you're going to use what's the
relationship between a Squared's and he
spreads and B spreads doing about B
squared equals a squared for the lips
good now you can use that right in fact
once I expand it you like oh look
there's even an a squared a squared
there okay so I'm gonna get you guys as
your first bit of my keys to finish
proving this question using these
identities